I've never seen it with the speed just as you. And i k. I'm jenny del i lived at nimbin for eleven years.
From nine hundred seventy four. Having arrived from england. And i had come to australia.
To see if there was any form of counter culture here till i didn't want to remain living in england where i've been
brought up and. Having arrived at puss and and then travelled on to adelaide of a sort of.
Asking everywhere i went if there was any alternative culture.
Around australia and it turned out that it was a year after the.
Aquarius festival had been held at nimbin and the closer i got to the eastern states.
The more people were saying oh you should check out nimbin. So i arrived here.
Actually on my way to the as a tin table and which i thought would be a nice place to go and look at it and godhood.
Also alternative lifestyle as. Living up there too. And the.
Arrived in nimbin on a sunday afternoon and went into the craft shop and asked ways the commune and.
Everybody fell about laughing because that was what everyone who arrived at nieman always used to us as a commune and.
The only commune. At that time was not strictly speaking a commune but a co-operative.
That had been bought immediately after the. Aquarius festival. It was about. At that time.
Twelve hundred acres of land in a valley that had once had a sawmill at the end of it so.
There was quite a lot of tree loss and. On the land already.
But it had been sold by a guy called sam a come to a co-operative of. I think it was nine hundred shareholders.
After the aquarius festival and.
And set up as a sort of piece of liberated land in a way that was no longer on the open market.
But that foot two hundred dollars and a fifty dollar joining fee. One could become a shareholder and.
And part of this extraordinary experiment in. Land ownership and. I arrived there with a caravan and.
A husband and two children. And we lived in the caravan for the first six months or so that we were there.
And then we're lucky enough to be able to move into one of the very few. Existing houses. On the property.
I think there were probably four or five old.
Ramshackle houses that had been pretty much derelict when the land was bought.
And we lived in one of those
and were considered also very lucky to have such a large roof over our heads because at that time.
It was very tough to tumble fools.
It was the only part of nine hundred seventy four that was the worst what season that people could remember a few years
news news. And. Most people who moved on to the land were living in temporary shelters or caravans a tent so.
Whatever they could sort of scrape together to keep the rain off them.
And basically survival was the name of the game nobody had very much money.
And so in a way we were very dependent on each other for help and support and transport. Because i knew one.
Family and maybe five or six would actually have reliable transportation. And at that time tangible and one big truck.
Which frequently used to be used to take everyone to a dance or a party or. To the beach at the weekend or whatever.
When just straight. Well. I had a very precise impression of what it was i wanted the way that i wanted to live and.
Sitting up in the north of england. Through a very cold winter in one thousand nine hundred eighty three.
I looked at will that lasse's. To see.
On many levels where i would be the best place on the planet for me to live that would be possible for me to live
because of. You know immigration.
Allowances and that sort of stuff so i was a track to two definitely a warm climate i wanted to be somewhere warm
when i first looked at what used to be called british hundred years.
Which is now billy's in central america and that is very appealing and i looked into that very carefully and.
But from those investigations it looked as if you know. To live the way that i wanted to live.
Would be quite difficult there. Because of the. You know sort of political situation in central and south america and.
At that time most radia had a white just really a policy. It had conscription. And it was involved in the vietnam war.
And all of that all of those things were most unappealing to me and.
Particularly conscription because i had a baby son and.
So i had to discount it destroyed you know as i for an english person who wanted to go
and live in a warm climate it was the obvious place to choose but then a lot of television
and radio coverage was given in england to go for it limbs campaign. For election.
I guess it was nine hundred seventy three and. I watched that and was very interested in this guy.
He was very favorably portrayed in the english media and.
When he was elected and announced an amnesty for draft dodgers and the end of the white australia policy.
I thought that's it. I'm going to australia. That that. It's the place i want to be. But in terms of.
Counterculture i didn't know what would what would be existing here but i didn't know.
That i wanted to live in an area well away from. Major cities. Where it will be possible to grow one set of food. With.
I even had a sort of. Pretty clear idea of the kind of landscape.
That i'd like to live in which was hills with lots of fresh running water. Not too far from the coast and.
That i would want to be living in close proximity to a large number of like minded people.
But not necessarily in a communal household.
As such because i've had some experience of communal living in england and. Had found that for other people.
More than for myself. Young children in a communal household can be quite a problem.
Because parents have different ways of bringing kids up and so on and. It could lead to friction and difficulty.
So my vision was that i would have my own little sort of. Unit. With my kids but very close to an co-operative.
A large group of other people and. So it turned out that. When i arrived at nimbin.
Exactly that was starting to grow there and. It was so close to to my vision of how i wanted to live.
I couldn't have been closer it was exactly the sort of ideas that i'd had.
So i felt immediately connected to the people here as if you know. This was like a long lost family or something and.
I'm very quickly. Settled in. To living here. And in those days. Really. None of us. Had anything.
You know we were all very poor. We had no money we had no jobs.
We were pretty dependent on government benefits in the early days as well which is you know.
An aspect of of nimbin life that i've had many differing positions on and.
The one i feel now is quite different from the one i had then i guess.
But in the early days we look to the dole as a form of rural subsidy where it allowed.
People like us selves to establish ourselves.
On degraded land and there's no doubt that the land was terribly degraded by use of over. Grazing.
And being used this past year in the daring kathleen destry. And also from being overlooked and eroded because of that.
So we felt that we were there to put something back into the land and. And also take the land. Off.
The the endless cycle of capitalism. And property. As in length being. Being a sort of form of currency. That.
By the very active put using it cooperatively and having rules that said.
It could never be sold without everyone's agreement we actually took a lend out of that situation.
Which was you know ideologically. An agreement that we all had and one of the very few things that we will agree john.
And i think because we was so poor that we had to depend on each other and we had to.
We had to live very closely together and share an awful lot of things that. Suburban families and people.
You know who live sort of ordinary lives in the outside world. Doesn't share it and.
That's a very texan thing to do and it doesn't always not always a smooth path.
And i think looking back on those early years of time to bill foles in the mid to late seventy's. The.
The stuff that we learned about living with other people about human nature.
About us about tolerance and compassion and.
Sort of looking at something from other people's points of view and from many points of view. Was it was beyond price.
I can't imagine a better training than than that and it seems now that the children who were babies.
And now in their late teens and early twenty's. Have grown up steeped in that culture and. Have in the. Into the world.
Incredibly enraged.
And i'm not you know any comparison is odious but i really think that that the kids that grew up that.
Joining that time and surrounded by that kind of activity have to have something extra you know that other kids.
Unfortunately. You know. Don't have unless they've lived in in very special circumstances will say.
Well i sing i think that was one of the reasons why i did would the fact that it was very hard to make rules and.
And have everybody agreeing on the same issues i think was one of the reasons why it was possible for everyone to stay
there because i think if there had been a very rigid structure. Then it wouldn't have. We would too individualistic.
And it wouldn't have worked and people. People would have fought to hide.
But interestingly although i've just sort of eulogized how wonderful.
The effect of it was on the kids that there was things about kids that if that for me didn't work and in fact.
Constitutes a reason why i left. Tumble fulls off to two years. And that was that.
It was very nice a fit and anything goes with kids and.
I was a parent to who i was choosing the counter-culture i was choosing. You know. To reduce.
Everywhere i could around me the films of all sorrow and dominance. That. I was wanting to expel from my life.
At the same time. I felt that. To bring children up within the boundaries and no limits.
Was quite a confusing thing to do. And it was putting too much responsibility on tiny children.
To constantly be giving them choices.
About what time they went to bed or you know how far they could roam or whether they got home before dark or norseman.
I'm talking about. You know children from eighteen months.
Up to say six years old because there weren't many a time to play at that time who were older than six might be wanted
to but not many and my children were very small and the children ran in a pack and that was terrific and.
It was you know. There were many advantages in that. But there were also disadvantages. In that.
I felt some other parents weren't quite as. King to take responsibility for their kids' whereabouts and activities.
As i was and. I was in very much a minority in wanting to set limits around my kids. And in the end. It happened that.
Doc nice fella and. Barney he was an eighteen months old. Had been out with the kids all day and.
I didn't know why she was it had been writing the creek was up.
It was a worrying time and a tumble when it's dark it's stuck. No lighting. The street lights ringing.
And i went across the creek to the family whose children she was. I knew she was and they were all stunned. And i said.
You know. Bunny hasn't come home and i'm really worried. And they all loved and said it's cool.
And i thought no i've had enough of this i don't i don't want to live like this is scary and.
She got home and she was ok. But all the same. I began to feel that you know.
I really needed to get the kids away from a situation like that now.
That was a decision i had to make for my own peace of mind and it.
And it doesn't mean to say that children who remained in that situation haven't emerged. Just as wonderful and.
You know. To refute kids is as could be.
But for me it was a bit too uncomfortable specific me that was one thing that didn't what.
Well it was a natural part of life. You know it was it was a part of life it was part of everybody's life.
I can't think of anyone who had no experience no that wouldn't of been anyone who had no experience of being smoked
around them. And there wouldn't have been many people who wouldn't. You know have a type of the joined as it went by.
But at that time. Also very importantly in that context.
There was only one person that i knew of at that time who lived on timetable fulls who went to the pub.
Who drank a chill. I mean. Occasionally people. Would have a drink.
I knew the guys would have a beer or something like that
but it was only one person who i would have identified who had a drinking problem. You know who drank.
All the time and got drunk and abusive and horrible. And. And it was. Nobody nobody thought of going to the pub it was.
It wasn't part of our culture to go to the pub. As time went by. I that changed quite dramatically. Right.
But on occasions with. I remember when there was a big. Police bust attended by nine hundred seventy eight.
And everyone was taken into his war and kept in custody all die and then they were let out in the evening
and then they all went to the pub and. They all got drunk and. They ate. They came back in the town to the red truck.
And you could hear the truck when it hit the top of the valley and. From where i live that was about two miles away.
And you could hear them singing in the truck as they came down the valley and. They were incredibly drunk.
And i'd never seen that before and it was the only and.
Oh since actually i've never seen a whole lot of tunnel people incredibly drunk. All in a big panic.
That was very unusual.
The drug bust was it was a day buckle from beginning to end but at the time it was very frightening.
At that time i suppose it would have been about him and about two hundred people living at a time to pull in various.
Doings some houses in close to construction some existing houses and tents and so on
and it was a simple tiny is right on several pumps of the community because we had established little hamlets which
were like tiny villages in the valley. That were clustered around central facilities like you know washing up and.
Shower and toilet facilities and. The police arrived. Before dawn. It was a commando style. Right they were in the.
There was some uniformed and some. Plainclothes police. There i didn't sort of trucks like coverage.
Trucks and sort of.
The ones that came down to me where i lived at the north and a short distance from where i was living.
And right next to the house of. The guy who'd originally owned the land and still hadn't.
And after he had sold it that he could live there until his day and.
The first person to become away it before doing that they were there was his housekeeper who was a middle aged. Nimbin.
Secular as she was that you were an original person of the area.
Who had never had anything to do with marrow honor
and who his life had been quite changed by the advent of two hundred hippies into her backyard.
But she was a most loving and compassionate and tolerant woman and. Very friendly was all of this very kind.
And it was her birthday and. She woke up. To to see this. Shadow of a truck.
Coming under the trees and then these figures in uniforms with guns.
Jumping out of the truck and she was absolutely terrified. As well you'll as these guys. You know approached.
Various doing so and. You know came in and intent everything upside down looking for marijuana.
Which i when you think back on it. It was very foolish it was august. You know.
And i mean anyone who knows anything about the marijuana growing season would not come looking for anything you know.
Any way they came and. Course they found little.
Stashes of little ends of joints and stuff in practically every house they visited. Naturally. And.
And they took people from just about every household into. Lismore and.
Fingerprinted and photographed and charge them all with position and.
I wasn't among the people arrested but there were people in my household who would taken it and.
I mean the whole thing was terribly frightening and there was so many young children attend to bill at that time and.
One of their early childhood experience used to be a commando style right on their home and the removal of.
Significant adults in their life from their environment. People who they'd experienced as being homeless humor. Yes.
Gentle people had to be so violently removed from their homes was was really a shocking thing to happen.
And you know i mean none of us were living there.
In order to subject our kids and ourselves to that kind of shocking violence. But it happened. And eventually the.
Due process was observed and everyone had to appear in court and the scene at the lismore courthouse on the day
when the charges were to be on said was extraordinary we had musicians and dances and.
People looking beautiful and soaks and settings and a festival atmosphere inside the coach house and.
And some pretty smart lawyers from sydney as well and a barrister and.
It was discovered quite early in the piece that the original warrant. Had actually been invalid.
And the police ended up with egg on their faces and all the charges had to be dropped and. Nothing came of it.
But what remained was the fact that we had been violated. That the community had been violated.
Sure it may be that you know if we had been breaking we lure in a big way
or the been anyone living there who at that time was making enormous amounts of money out of growing marijuana.
That there might have been a little more excuse for it in their wallets.
But i suppose it's the sort of tax you pay on on turning your back on some of the rules of the society.
And deciding that you can set up under a different set of rules. And we certainly paid that tax. Subsequent is.
There were people in that area. Who were growing a lot of marijuana for profit and.
That's you know felt very good to me either. It you know. As that started to happen i'm.
I began to feel that i wasn't really interested in that either. You know. And of course a lot of this now.
Who were you know into the culture then i'm not seeing it now. I mean we've grown out of it or you know whatever.
But it did become. I think a little over represented at nieman and certainly over represented there now and.
It's a problem that. That's become a problem where in the very early years. It was actually part of the solution.
It wasn't a problem a tool and in fact a lot of people are not a lot of people but.
You know a good dozen or so people came to name been in order to get away from the cities. Who had been drug addicted.
In the past to hunt drugs like heroin specifically.
And they came to name been in order to be away from that culture
and successfully stayed away from it because there wasn't any heroin at nieman
and the little marijuana that people grew and. Sort of shared among themselves. Was. Was used in much the same way as.
People have a drinks cabinet you can allow households and. It was a form of relaxation and.
You know some people used it as a creative stimulant or whatever.
And i didn't seem to be such a problem but over the years a lot of people became very dependent on it and.
You know i don't believe you can really be addicted to marijuana and this you are an addictive personality and.
You know if it wasn't marijuana it would be something else. But certainly some of the behavior is.
Later on when when there are people who become habituated over many years to using large quantities of marijuana.
That begin to look at you know a bit weird because. It does tend to zap you of motivation and.
Energy and perhaps have been achieved without it. When i really don't know.
But i would say that it certainly wasn't until the eighties. And i don't know how far into the eighty's.
It's quite an extraordinary thing for me personally that.
You know despite having been part of the counterculture for so long and having known heaps of junkies and.
You know people who. Been using i've never actually seen heroin. In my whole life. And so.
I really i only became conscious so much i suppose about eighty to eighty three. That there were people who were using.
Or at least tasting. You know it's not like she regularly uses.
I think it was around that time that i became aware that. One of the daughter of.
Some people that i sort of didn't know. Really well but i knew quite well.
And i had a daughter who at that time would have been about seventeen sixteen i think. And that she was using and this.
And that seemed to me really shocking and i hadn't really been away it.
But then i became aware that there were other adults who who had been using and that i was sharing it was.
Yes it was in my kids who have been coming to be close to teenage and. That was very scary.
That there was a teenager in town who you know had been offered and accepted. The use of heroin.
It was quite alarming to me. And. Yeah. I didn't feel like it was a good place to. Just a once a kids.
Came to be that age. Also because by that time. I was living in the main street of town. Which.
It's a very very different situation from living out in the hills as most people did.
That i don't think all of them may have been two or three other people living in town.
You know who were part of the sort of new settler movement and the main street is sort of where it all happens
and it's often said of me in the i think it's true that.
It probably doesn't have any more problems than other places but at nimbin they're really out front.
There on the street.
You can see them they're not he'd no way now that he's pushed out of sight under the carpet sort of thing.
You know i think that is one of what.
You know why it's a problem in another way it's one of the great blessings of nimbin that that.
That it's such a tolerant community and. So tolerant of deviance. But to. This is a sense in which.
That was ok when we were in a you know. Early twenty's and we would.
As a group of people we tended to throw the baby out with the bathwater. You know we'd thrown out old customs and.
Belief systems and values set up parents had sort of instilled in us and.
We're gradually reus simulating what seemed to be important to us and holding onto a certain.
Perhaps a new set of values that we created for ourselves we were certainly creating a whole new culture and.
So in that since we were very open to new definitions of what was right and wrong what was ok and not ok.
And that was fine but i think. As we grow now. And we're now in our thirty's forty's and fifty's.
Most of us who were there then are enough forty's now. I think we've needed. Two. To set a few more limits.
And we've been prepared to say it and it is time for that now.
And we haven't done quite enough of it from the other side.
Well i hope we've grown wise that we've certainly grown old
and that doesn't mean to say that there isn't an extraordinary. Youthfulness about his soul.
You know for being enough forty's and fifty's was still ready at the drop of a hat for a right. Danson. You know.
I mean we have very energetic people for this but almost unbelievable age and.
I think there's something about having spent that is used that name and that's kept us. Mentally very youthful.
And spiritually youthful yet. The rules of men and women on time to bull.
In particular in the early years were not that dissimilar from. Out in the rest of society in the sense that to.
The women tended to get the household duties and. The men tended to be out there.
Doing whatever they did out there and. In the case of timetable that was largely a matter of clearing a site.
And building a house and. It wasn't so much divided along sexist lines per se as.
It was down to whose physical energy was most appropriate to the tusk.
And given that most of the women who were there and the women many women. They were nearly all men.
And the women who would there were generally. Either.
Relationship with a guy or a single parent so babies were involved in nearly every case and. That being the case.
It was most sensible for the guy to be the one who was clearing the site and building the house.
And for the woman to be the one who was washing the nappies. In a bucket. You know with no.
Washing machine or anything like that and. Keeping an eye on the kids.
That's not to say that that was richard but it was generally how it filled.
And we used to have a women's group that met in nimbin. Once a week.
And that was the one night of the week when the guys got the kids no matter how they felt about it and.
There was you know quite a lot of uproar about that too and.
City feminists who visited our meeting was absolutely a pull that we you know it's us will had to fight with our guys
to get in to look after the kids one night a week so we go to a meeting. But also the rest of it.
Do you know that in their view it was. It was divided. So rigidly along six this law and so occupation.
But from up point of view.
You know i mean more than anything we come here for peace and harmony and happiness and that seemed to be.
The way that we would you know that things would be most peaceful and how many of us.